Чудо. Запис, розпочато я думаю, що ми тоді можемо стартувати сьогодні наші заняття Загалом, що ми будемо сьогодні робити окремо на початку і далі?
Все ж таки, підемо до роботи перше це те, що Сергій олексійович Германа першого заняття лекційного про те, що будемо більш практично розглядати розробку себеної частини тут просто розглянемо як будувати найпростіші.
глянули що у нас було зроблено. І все ж таки трошки передивилися. Які завдання. Правильно були виконані я включу зараз демонстрацію екрану тоді і ми можемо з вами так це буде ось.
Ось.
Так. Чи видно? Так. Чудово.
Так я бачу. У нас Загалом, лишилося перший бачу в нас лишився лише 1 день. Трайлом, безкоштовний версій тому але це питання ми вирішимо і загалом, подивимось на бек-вокспрети то те, що в нас лишилося фактично з минулого у нас було зроблено.
3 завдання.
В процесі в нас 2 завдання я бачу одне на веронік степанів. І одне на нас лізабережна є чи є якийсь прогрес по цим завданням Можливо, знаєте, вероніка у нас є можлива як відбувається прогрес за розробкою дизайну сторінки підлогу.
Ну, дизайну. Мене здається, вже повністю готовий я можу показати його я думала: вам на стандарти показувала ні.
Та так показували можливо, Сергійович також хоче побачити як Клієнт частину дизайну Лялька вже є.
Вогонь.
Дякую. Павло володимировичу тут, Схоже, як кажуть, я як викладач.
У.
Припустився певної помилки щодо планування заняття і таке інше. Андрійович, каже, що ймовірно, я сплутав Коли в нас там пара і тощо я приношу свої вибачення через помилки планування рівнився, у вівторок, спробую розібратися, вибачте, де я на портатів не я Дякую.
Що ви змогли приєднатися навіть у такому режимі. Щось, ще раз. Приношу свої вибачення.
Це моя помилка. І користуючись випадком якщо є така можливість продемонструвати той варіант умовно фінальним для дизайну Будь ласка, буде торгівлю ще радий.
От Тоді зараз вмикаю.
Так, це Здається, я показувала. Так, це з самого початку. Було далі. Я так в інструменті.
Це не моя частина. Я зробила. Події. Це пока календар планування подій.
Цю частину ми бачили.
Щоб розуміла, які у нас подальші.
Заходи є Це У нас виходить. Анкета з працевлаштуванням.
І зв'язок як зв'язатися з нами отакі у нас сторінки.
Щиро дякую. Витримана, в одному стилі тощо навіть реклама є такою що дійсно захопливо захоплива виглядає як дизайн марно як клієнт потенційний перепрошую.
І навіть як замовник, задоволеним Дякую.
Дякую. Вам. Усі все. Це дім.
Чудово. Дякуємо за демонстрацію. Тоді я думаю, що можна передвинути. Це завдання.
Зроблене так і стосовно дизайну, монстрапедії навчив взяти в нас а ви є все добре.
Я тут я його роблю але я зараз його трішки перероблюю, щоб був як у вероніки, дизайн, щоб схоже, було але в мене вже є головна сторінка, можна так, сказати.
Ага.
Так. Тоді лишаємося завдання. В прогресії і тоді я вже то робите можна буде глянути на фінальний результат щоб тоді вже дивитися що буде Чудово!
Майже.
Дон.
Тоді в нас залишається глянути 2 завдання програмної частини це у нас таке перенесення дизайну шапки. Сайту програмну частину сайту і розробка сторінки блогу чи працює хтось над цими завданнями.
Not so much of Danyamunas.
Чудово. Так.
зміню дійсно ж бажаю.
створити такі завдання більше до Можливо, створення якоїсь репозиторією, сербраної частини Тому що це буде окремий в історію, в якому ви будете зберігати все правильну частину сайту.
Що скажете? На таке?
I suppose Lahar.
Звісно, я говорив про те, що Можемо ще додатково середзиденти які бачать що є вже програмної частини, але поки чекайте, дизайну тому я пропонував можна створити ще одне завдання, яке більше буде до створення репозиторів, для серверної частини, сайту.
Чудово, тоді давайте створимо.
З вами завдання Так?
Пункт можу сказати, що це у нас буде користувацька історія і що я як власне, продукту починати а зараз не.
На все ж.
Певної частини Хай Тут трошки молочка.
Це перетин сюди частина сайту для розчину.
Для контролю версію чи цілком чудовий опис і тоді ми створюємо на основі цієї користувацької історії, яке завдання, яке Саме ж таке варити при позиторі для серверної частини.
ж таки тому що більша частина дизайну вже розроблена тобто нас лишається лише програма А далі ми будемо оглядати все ж таки як успіхи йдуть тому, що як бачимо, на минулий в принт, ми запланували занадто багато і тому, цілком адекватно.
Я думаю, лишити поки що 4 за завдання як за минулий спринтну фактично було зроблено 3.
чути а зараз я покажу вам, простенький приклад. Як загалом і го встановити Гаразд.
Демонстрацію екрану.
Чудово.
Ось в нас є трошки більше зараз екран добре вам видно.
Чудо як із тут страпом Загалом, дуже гарна практика, якщо ви хочете чогось, навчитись то заходите на офіційний сайт, і дивитися що у нас там є тому що частіше за все це буде найновіші.
Приклади які можна знайти аніж те, що ви знайдете в Інтернеті, а повної відтоді наприклад, там можуть бути застарілі, або вже не використовують практики, у нас є навіть Ось, я бачу переклад, українською невпевнений стосовно цей документ є застарілим.
На жаль тому доведеться нам повернутися на англійську версію документації, я вам посилання у чат.
Ось у нас ми навіть на головній сторінці кажуть, що це мінімалістичний веб-франй-борк для наочес Фактично, у нас є приклад, як створити найпростішу серверну частину оскільки тут 9 рядків.
Коду. Люди дуже швидко порівняно з іншими флейбуками Але перш ніж нам працювати нам все ж таки, треба завантажити норд.
S Тобто, Чесно. Навантажуються просто переходити за посиланням також у нас є посилання натискайте завантажити на дєс і от нас вона пропонує його завантажити я завантажу не буду тому що він вже є встановлений.
Але фактично це просто звичайний Екс-файл який ви запускаєте і у вас буде доступно вже наоджерства, не потрібно нічого налаштовувати.
Повертаючись до експрес усе ж таки От у нас є де-факто і тут у становленні і от вони нам дають якісь приклади, це ж тварини нам говорять що ми вже думаємо що ви встановили, над єс тобто нам потрібно встановити проект, і відкриваємо вони ось це роблять за допомогою рядку але нам це не
потрібно тому ми використаємо. Наш ось такий я створив простенький. З минулих занять у нас був припустиморій який вживл, студіо-код більш трошки і от я тут створив мінімалістичний приклад.
Е чтемело над якийсь там сайт і оцскрипт який я під'єднав туди.
От фактично що нам потрібно нам говорять, кристович нпм нам потрібно створити такий що таке є емпіон фактично інтем це частина часу, це є пакетний менеджер.
експрес в інших мовах програмування є схожі механізми які ви можете використовувати ось такий джаз крута є купа альтернатив але поки що ми сфокусуємо лише нації, і от нам говориш нам треба виконати наступну команду мп і Ні, йдемо у віжел-студію відкриваємо
термінал і вводимо По-перше, нам треба перевірити, все ж таки чи існує в нас емпіон от якщо у вас може бути така проблема.
Що Павер Шел і якщо він у нас відкритий відкрився пауерша ось тут збоку.
То він може говорити, що я не буду такі команди, використовувати для того, щоб це виправити ви натискаєте Ось сюди біля плюс відкриваєте і тут лантарів потрібний команд пророт фактично це звичайний командний рядок будемо тут темпі і бачимо що він тут чудово.
Виконується у нас тут нема. Обмежень як упав Варшава і Ми виконуємо Мпм Ініц ініціалізація і вони нам.
Тут говорять ім'я. Пакету Ми використовуємо таке Цей папки версію також натискаємо Ентер.
Нам не важливо. От воно нам, говорить що Але Ні, у нас має бути Індекс єс ми створимо.
файл тобто такий простенький. Досить все те що нам говорили Тобто тут є назва вашого сайту, тут я його версію якщо ви платите його на роботі, забира опис і таке інше.
ще систему створити тут кажемо: що новий файл у нас новий пустей файл.
Фактично нічого немає. То Тепер нам говорять Ну, давайте встановимо експрес як встановити емпієнт Стол експрес легко робимо повторюємо те ж саме, що нам говорять, стол.
Експрес і тепер у нас Бачите, зайняло лише 2 секунди. І от вона нам додало 66 пакетів і вас Таким чином, з'явилося над модулі фактично це просто купа різних залежностей, які потрібні для тієї чи іншої бібліотеки папку їх народ і також у вас з'явиться пеке-члок який описує які
версії були використані і змінився. У нас також Пекель з чийсом тут додався.
часу не забуваємо зберігати і що у нас тут відбувається. Ми можемо розділити це все на 3 основних частини перша частина це ми отримаємо потрібні об'єкти, щоб працювати з експресом.
Нам треба використовувати експрес фактично отримати цю бібліотеку в нашому чанускриптурі цю функцію тому металі отримаємо f за допомогою якого об'єкт ми вже будемо маніпулювати і Віктор олексійович вказував на занятті нам потрібно також вказувати
Порт класично нас іде 3 000 Ми можемо змінити а може не змінювати Польщі пойшло на трьох 1 000 і от далі у нас є приклад.
Створення. Кет? Так. Цієї точки фактично от, нас як Гет Так.
і рес вони фактично є. Квест та ресторан Запит та відповідь і От ми у відповідь відправляємо клубу і остання частина це ми говоримо що ми хочемо слухати, підключитись до цього порту?
достатньо Ми пишемо. Нот і просто вказуємо в пая індекс щез і бачимо, що акценту Ер в лисини пантоль 3 000 нас виявилося, він успішно.
Слухає на трьох 1 000 що нам треба зробити нам тепер Фактично, треба зробити так що ми хочемо отримати доступ до колгосп ми відкриваємо його і одне село колгосп 3 000.
І ми переходимо на нього це Фактично, сервер і бачите ми отримуємо у відповідь ось цей холобору.
нас показується, які запити, були реально зроблені у нашому випадку, ми бачимо, що у нас був зроблений запис запит 103 000 Тобто відповідь ми підтримали халов урок і фактично ми Таким чином, створили найперший на дуже базовий додат далі.
локолгос- 3 000 чудово. Ми хочемо зробити з нашого члена сайту індексичний метод зробити запит до нашого сайту на все вам відчисти Так, Він Індекс шти-мал У мене Він вже є чудово, якийсь там сайт Тобто Ми його отримали і тепер спробуємо додати сюди.
кліп.
Це фактично буде спрацьовувати коли ми натискаємо накл, і ми там, хочемо використати виконати якийсь метод, центру як бачите, я тут підключив тест Джеймс Тобто, локально, тут файлучого скрипту який у нас саме такий буде поєднаний Індексом чином і тут ми створимо функцію
відправити ми можемо легко простувати Чи взагалі воно у нас працює створити якийсь консульлог і перевірити Чи вона буде працювати для того, щоб перевірити що в нас вводиться в консолі ми Знову ж таки, натискаємо Le-фа львів?
На жаль, не можу збільшити шрифт панелі розробника. Тому якщо буде не видно.
Й ані все ж таки, вийшло збільшити чудово, І Ми натискаємо відправити Наприклад, Так, нам треба оновити точаюсь ее Так, я забув зберегти Так, зберігаємо ештемел-пайл вновлюємо файл і бачимо що от у нас болгарський консоль що те, що у нас працює.
5 ми будемо використовувати найменш складному вигляді просто Ось феч персно що нам треба це вказати куди ми будемо робити запит Думаю, що читач нам допомагає робити екіпі запити до різних частин для того, щоб це зробити ми йдемо і використовуємо 4-піпій крапку ssssle- 3
І фактично поки що це все, але нам потрібно щоб він об'єктивно щось робив, і ми отримали відповідь, себе для того, щоб це зробити ми використовуємо можу використовувати проміси.
Після того, як ми отримали, все ж таки дані, ми хочемо їх у нас це буде вже рядок, який ми отримали, і ми хочемо його просто вивести на екран.
запити. Тобто ми не можемо ми можемо дозволити. Всім робити. Якщо ми хочемо зробити публічне оп-ай Але в більшості випадків, це не працює.
Тому що це не є дуже небезпечним, тому ми робимо так що лише от наш локальний сайт, може робити запити до нашого сервер більш детально ми це розглянемо коли ми будемо займатися все ж таки.
можемо отримати додамо ще 1 Термінал бачите Ми можемо додавати їх.
Декілька і ось тут антиєм Відстол Орс. І от у нас додалися якийсь пакет і для того, щоб експрес-тест нас його використовував ми це робимо за допомогою ат крапка йоус піт тут вказуємо ось так і це функція та мама її викликає Чудово.
5 запит до нашого серверу і отримали дуже базову відповідь у вигляді тексту честіше за все текст ніхто не використовує хоча більше він не використовується у такому вигляді тому використовується дуже часто Джайсон так Джейсон це проста структура, яка використовується
джаз-скрипті створення об'єктів, але вона і використовується для обміну між серверами ну, так як ми всюди, використовуємо джаз-крит тому нам це не буде проблемою, наприклад, скажемо що ми хочемо повернути ну, більш складний об'єкт і.
От створимо наприклад, п'юзарс яка буде в нас повертати всіх користувачів і створимо ось таких цих льозочок, у нас буде масив там об'єктів.
І це в нас буде Ну, скажемо, наприклад, у їхнє, ім'я, там.
І їхній Ньюзерней ім'я користувач.
тепер ось вже і сон форматі і ми фактично можемо там отримати.
Наприклад, ми хочемо отримати ім'я першого користувача. Оновлюємо сторінку і от ми отримали нею.
Тобто Таким чином, ми отримали зміну. Яку нам було потрібно.
От тепер спробуємо. У нас Тепер є користувачі фактично кінця. Точка, яка використовує яка нам повертає всіх користувачів.
Ну, давайте тепер спробуємо зробити більше все ж таки, реєстрацію. Так ми хочемо зробити реєстрацію.
який ми отримали, до цієї точок, доступу, ми створюємо перезавантажимо сервер і повертаємось до нашої все ж таки частини з штимелем, давайте напишемо їм дуже простенький ага дизайн, Наприклад, ми будемо вказувати користувача, і його пароль юзер гм от наприклад,
Б'юзердн.
Звісно, розділювач. Ну що паливо. Ось хоч так було добре, Ну і тут якщо кнопки. Також щось роблю дуже мінімалістичний дизайн ні, до чого.
Нас не буде от скаже Ну, користувачі кліп а як нам отримати якісь дані звідси а для цього ми все ж таки, йдемо, назад в тест чаєс та і у нас тут є була функції відправити.
Ми хочемо отримати рості далі, поки що давайте закомендуємо наш запит щоб ми його не робили кожен раз, ми хочемо отримати наприклад, ім'я користувачів, півзерней для цього ми використовуємо документ це фактично весна з чималоток метрів.
Тут є Кет-елемент Байті як я вказував, до цього що ми можемо вказати, отримати Елемент по всьому Айді а от у нас як дідо-зерней дайте його вкажемо як рядок, і далі ми хочемо отримати його значення.
Це буде. Велій.
Давайте спробуємо. Вивести на екран, те, що ми все ж таки, отримали так щоб ми розуміли, що кожен кожну частину нашої розробки ми отримуємо те, що ми хочемо те, що користувач львів для ім'я користувача.
Зробимо теж саме для пароль так само вказуємо кіно ось глянемо що ми там отримаємо Взагалі.
Ще це щось Обидва поля працюють наприклад?
Так нам треба оновити сторінку.
І тут бачите тобто ми отримали 2 і тут також ще дуже корисно панелі, розробника ми можемо бачити де саме у нас виявилося конкретний рядок, тобто якщо ми натиснемо тут ее був виданий на екран.
вказуємо ось такий об'єкт а в нас цьому об'єкт є купа різного але ми хочемо метод так вказуємо метод ну ми хочемо пост чудово.
Нам також треба є гарний стиль вказувати те, що ми хочемо відправляти для цього нам потрібні вказати хедерс тут заголовки і тут ми вкажемо за допомогою такого контент таль тобто тип контенту.
Файл і от як він нам говорить що він конвертує джагосп-об'єкт в Джерісон рядок це те, що нам треба і от ми створюємо і там пишу Мізернен і паску.
Тобто, у даному випадку, як тіло ми будемо відправляти, е-сте чи то приберемо все ж таки також поки що наші тому що ми не будемо відповідь ніяк отримувати від севера. Повертаємось до нашого сайту перше зберігаємо його і от поновлюємо сайт, і скажемо ми хочемо якийсь там.
І тут якісь сказати так і натискаємо відправити О, нам пише що нотфаут тому що ми повертаємося наш серверу тому що вона в нас називається речі а ми там вказали бачите, хоч у нас і існує точка але фактично кінцева точка, не є так типу який ми хотіли відправити якщо ми переглянемо в
нас триває. Чому так того, що сервер ми не налаштували для того, щоб він відправив нам якусь відповідь Тобто, він нічого не робить.
Ми не хочемо того бачите. Тобто ми бачимо що ми до нього ви відправили паспорт.
Та але ми їх бачимо отримати все ж таки звідси щось Але бачите, у нас є 2 типи запиту коли ви робите Будь-який запит ви отримаєте найчастіше А отаке.
Прифлайт обшац на минулому Занятті Якщо ви пам'ятаєте то вказувались Ті що методи запитів, які рідко використовуються це 1 із тих він робиться автоматично використовуємо власноруч.
Він використовується в автономічному режим тепер от у нас є все ж таки працюю.
Перевіримо що у нас сервер так як ви пам'ятаєте, ми вказали що Ну, ми хочемо в йоза в речі стартичнішим? В вивести на екран, просто запит, який ми отримали.
Як це з У нас вийшло? Як ми бачимо, що в нас тут важкий об'єкт, але це не дуже важливо.
Але можемо бачити, що в ньому взагалі є і що ми могли б отримати не все, з цього нам потрібно хто тут можна отримати але нам потрібно пошукати, дякую.
Чи отримали ми якесь тiо ось для цього поглянемо все ж таки Чи відправилось нам щось тому що поки що нічого не видно, так?
За трошки; вище.
Ти глянемо якісь методи тут бачите, у нас запит, є досить великим. В цьому плані От ми бачимо що нас який метод, був відправлений.
Так? Це все ж не те.
що фактично у нас частина з дизайну, наша частина все ж таки, чекає на якусь відповідь від цирур А хірургії.
Не надає ось такий запит у нас ніколи не закінчується ми хочемо відправити 200 Після того, як ми прочитали: так це може використовувати сенс статус.
антифайд треба розібратися чому переглянемо наш тест ми бачимо що так нацбаді є. І воно начебто без проблем Так.
Чому ж нас немає тіла в?
Так. Переглянемо зараз. Треба розуміти. Десь було зроблено.
Помилка. Скоріше за все так тут ми отримали так Але все ж таки, ми отримаємо Антифайн чомусь.
Тут У нас все правильно. Був.
Це перевіримо, що у нас тут.
Та об'єкт у нас є.
Фактично.
Так. Ми відправляємо Чийсон: чудово. Ага. Нам треба ще додатково писати, щоб дозволити читати, все ж таки експресо цей сон?
Нам треба йому вказати ось тупий ось ось таку частину чису ми його прибираємо він буде в нас.
Що? Я пам'ятаю правильно? То ось так, Е буде виглядати фактично можемо вам так.
Запит О, чудово ми отримали з вами потрібний Аа Джейсон тут бачите, у нас є ім'я користувача і пароль.
Що нам робити так ми можемо фактично, отримати і кожен елемент з ось цього.
Отриманого тіла.
Тому що ми бачимо, що він у нас був отриманий в такому вигляді, і він є цілком.
Адекватним тим, що ми відправили переживан теж майно і спробували відправити і ще раз і бачимо що ми чудово, його отримали простіше спосіб звісно, давайте спробуємо це так деструктуризація а тут фактично отримати нор ці 2 поля в ось такому вигляді на вказано їхнє, значення.
І звідти. Ми хочемо отримати і ось так ми отримаємо обидва значення так з нашого: запит ось тут давайте пароль зробимо.
Чудово, перезавантажимо наш сервер і все має працювати так само, як і працювали ще 1 запит робимо чудово, і ми отримуємо той же і все ж таки давайте зробимо так щоб ми там все було більш правильно тепер давайте приберемо всі ось імена які нам не потрібні.
І додамо сюди ну хай буде це 1 користувач там з паролем ось з кимось.
І ми хочемо додавати до всього об'єкту користувач користувачі уявимо що це база даних.
Нас ми хочемо додавати до нього Китай Ну, скажемо що дюзерс суш?
І От ми відпочинку є зернень і паска зазвичай зверніть увагу, що бачите тут ми вказано юзер не крапка і ось так якщо ми використовуємо зміні в яких ім'я співпадає.
З потрібним. Нам значення. Ми можемо просто вказувати лише назву.
тест-1 все ж таки, Добре, було б отримати їх в якомусь Давайте ще додамо простіше вигляді до нашої клієнтської частини додамо якийсь простеньку кнопку паркн.
От отримати там.
Вєт Йосиф тобто отримати Користувачі і ми будемо ми хочемо отримати всіх цих користувачів 5 в сторону таку ж саму функцію, створено йдемо до нашого тест, чиясу які нас приєднують до клієнтської частини, і тут створюємо якусь інформацію, кому ви казали, минулого разу
це Кет Фізис ми тут створимо дуже Простенькі речі який буде робити Запит до там лохолфост на 3 000 Йосип я там наприклад, це ми хочемо отримати Давайте тут будемо використовувати.
Отримувати Джайсон ми хочемо і далі ми отримати хочемо з цього трошки не 2 ось так і далі.
Ми використовуємо Христос скажемо, і хочемо, ну просто поки що спробуємо його вивести.
Так, ечкіно кимось навчив.
Ну, ось нехай нас буде ті в якийсь а момент хочемо дати а ті в п'юзес так, і от ми хочемо.
Документ Кет Елемент Пай Іді продюсер і тут можна використовувати інформацію і ми хочемо закинути фактично все що в нас є в республіці до цього елементу то інформація це внутрішній чиновник того, елементи одну і Кернесі і спробуємо у нас тут трошки помилка
і ось спробуємо це зробити ми додали декілька користувачів, ми все ж таки, хочемо їх.
Отримати схем. Макет юзерс бачимо що у нас об'єкт об'єкт все ж таки не те, щоб ми хотіли.
елементів, як нам через нього пройти досить-таки просто ми можемо створити пор по циклу, форми можна проходити до якого у нас ресторан, це буде його довжина і ми тут будемо збільшувати і що ми хочемо зробити так це.
Спробуємо наприклад, так, ось таким чином мало б спрацювати але будемо дивитися можливо, й ні.
Ігор Еспанс наприклад, Так, і зерни.
І його пароль.
Не дуже небезпечно. Звісно, ж, але ми поки що бачимо, там готуємо скажемо, панель адміністратор, хочу бачити.
користувачів тому нам би було мало сенсу знайти користувача, Спершу за його так у відпустку іври хоча б от ми тут вказуємо в функції файлів.
Ми це можемо влаштувати досить легко де ми ви шукаємо проходимо 1 000 користувачів, і знаходимо по якійсь умові потрібно користувача ми хочемо знайти того, який буде нас порівнювати юзер нею.
От бачите у нас кажуть: що вона повертає перше значення. Елементу. З масиву ми хочемо знайти елемент Тобто юзер ексис че-юзе взагалі існує і ми хочемо вказуємо Ось такого того, що він.
Просто вказано об'єкт то це перевіряє чи він не буде в нас антифайд скажемо, або давайте кажемо, напряму що він антибай ага Тобто, якщо він нерівний не позначені елементу, точно знають, що ми знайшли, його в масиві а це не є добре, тому що ми не хочемо мати на нашому сайті, 2
користувача. З однаковою ее логіку однаковим ім'ям. Ми використовуємо для цього аристонс ми хочемо Підправити кажучи, там енус юзеф Олдід екзист.
Чудово, і давайте випробуємо цю частину ми знаємо що в нас вже існує користувач, якщо вони там Ну, додамо якийсь тест, і ми бачимо що він у нас існує вже спробуємо ще раз додати бачимо що в нас по-перше, так стала спадок, так кінотеатр, що вони нам не можуть відправити якісь.
Так нам треба мабуть, додати сюди, статус тоді для цього ми можемо використовувати метод статусу Ось скажемо що це буде 400 і спробуємо відправити його мабуть, як джальсон щоб це було трошки простіше Ось Таким чином.
Так і все ж таки Чому нас. Це помилка. Виникла Тому що ми не використовували ретюрд Тобто медалі йшли додавали користувача.
запит бачимо, що нас вже черговим, зазначено ось так і бачимо, що так у нас 400 поганий запит який нам говорить що користувач вже існує і ми можемо там хоч скільки хочемо вказувати ала нам, будуть працювати А якщо кажма того, що не існує.
О, чудово. В нас Бачите, відправляємо Окей, і отримаємо того ж користувача.
Чудово тут бачите ми з вами змогли створити базу дуже реєстрацію за допомогою експрес-чес і бачу що у нас ще є 7 хвилин.
І я думаю, що було б чудово. Спробувати Ну, хоча б розгорнути можливо, спробувати встановити на честь та створити на вашому комп'ютері Ну, такий простенький по прикладах з сайту експрес-єс це верний та дат.
Можливо, в когось, є Зараз можливість відкрити я пішов студію завантажити.
Нучес Ну, якщо є у нас можливість відкрити віжу у студію. То ми з іншим не має бути проблем.
Давайте Я спробую.
Чудово. А в є Так.
Видно! Ого.
Так перше, що нам треба зробити я відправляв, у чат. 2 повідомлення. І вам треба По-перше, завантажити на якщо у вас звісно, його ще немає.
Ну.
Тобто перейдіть по посиланню. Я ось продублюєм.
Зараз! Ми не пусте.
Ну.
Так і от, Так завантажити натискайте дан лат Так уново.
Просто Він у мене вже Може бути.
Можемо перевірити? Можете відкрити. Ось вам тут. Треба вести нот і мінус 2 так Чудово.
Ловити.
Бачите у нас уже він встановлений. Тобто Нам не треба його версія 20, Нам також цілком підходить.
Давно.
Вона є. Досить новою далі. Спробуємо так як було, вказано в нашому тоторіалі з експрес-реєстру Ну, давайте спробуємо створити так мабуть, на так нову давайте мабуть, створимо.
Зараз Я вас стою. Папою. Бігав.
У.
Чудово. Тепер давайте спробуємо перше, що нам треба зробити це створити за допомогою Мм. Його ініціатив для цього відкрийте Термінал.
Зверху там або ось так можна так і бачите, перше, що нас відкрилося це павершин впав Рушел він частіше за все не працює.
Кого?
Тому нам треба відкрити бачите біля знаку плюс там є стрілочка вниз Так, і вам тут треба Так, команд про ось третє зверху чудово і тут напишіть мм пробіл ініт.
Експеримента.
Так. Ніт як ініціалізація Ось так чудово. І ось нам тут говорять що якісь там.
Можна з електроенергії для ініціалізації проект що проєкт не нам таке підходи просто натискаємо n.
Області Павлова.
рядки. Напишіть Мпн.
Потім вінстол.
Час Я намагаюсь збільшити.
Контрол. Плюс воно? Не о.
Ну, хто?
Так трошки ви було терміново відкрийте ще раз і тут треба написати мм і стол.
Так. Чи То І Експрес?
На Це скай темп.
У нас тут бачите і ми бачимо що у нас з'явилася папка. На от Модуль з'явився Ппкичлок і в самого пеки Джейсон є Запис про те, що.
Ого!
Це Можете запитати: Так. Можете відкрити Пек Джийсон зараз останній Так. І Бачите у нас тут на 12-му рядку.
Вказує, що от він у нас є експрес чудово. Тепер просто можете відкрити по посиланню.
Так зараз я не надішлю його іскопіюємо просто приклад тощо у нас був.
Ось на посилання можете його відкрити Ні. Давайте і От Копіюйте ось-ось.
Найпростіший приклад того, що в нас є Створюйте індекс.
І просто запитайте зберігайте і тепер нам треба його запустити для цього пишемо нот і вказуємо ім'я файл.
Чи то ви бачите на той момент говорить що воно є на цьому. Партії для того, щоб його отримати перевірити, що нас сервер працює можете вправи взагалі написати Ло колгосп адвокатка і 3 000 ото з.
Зараз в мене просто тут трішки не в дунда.
Все добре.
Е так, двокрапка і 3 000.
І ще дво краплі у нас зараз.
Бачите Тобто ви отримали фактично Таким чином, браузер, робить завжди кет запити Тобто ви запустили сервер і перевірили він у нас цілком чудово працює.
Ого!
І нам це вдалося я бачу, так близько семи хвилин, звісно ж, припираючи те, що ми ще не встановлюємо водночас.
дуже на найпростішому вигляді, якого ми оглянули А вже наступного заняття ми з вами спробуємо поглянути як підключити базу даних, і все ж таки, більше співпрацювати в реальному вигляді, в якому Зазвичай розробляють сайти і.
Ого!
Добре цікаво.
Чудово. Тоді можливо, які ще є запитання.
Побажання.
Оголене. Я Дякую. Павло Володимировичу Станіслав Андрійович колега.
сервер для власного програмного забезпечення і робиться це у гарному вигляді з використанням доцільних технологій найближчої середи вже ми зможемо побачити, певний прогрес який стосується Приватбанку як реєстрація користувачів.
У наступному.
Добре.
Дякую. І До зустрічі на все добре.
Дякую вам велике за урок До побачення. Гарного дня.
На побачення.
Побачення.